♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT," IN
APRIL OF 2019.
IT WAS BEFORE THE THIRD OR
FOURTH ATTEMPT AT THE OFFICE, AT
THAT MOMENT MOST AMERICANS
THOUGHT THEY KNEW WHO
JODEY ARRINGTON
JODEYJOE BIDEN WAS.
THEY WEREN'T FAMILIAR WITH HIS
NEW FACE.
TWO YEARS LATER, THEY APPEARED
IN MIAMI FOR THE FIRST OF FIRST
IMPORTED PRIMARY DEBATE AND HARD
TO RECOGNIZE, PEOPLE WHO HAD
KNOWN HIM.
MADE IT LOOK LIKE A DIFFERENT
PERSON.
BUT MOST JARRING WAS THE FACT
THAT HE DID NOT SOUND LIKE THE
OLD JOE BIDEN.
HE PROBABLY REMEMBERED THE BIDEN
AS JOVIAL, IRISH CHARM ON THE
BUCKET LIST.
HE WAS FAMOUS FOR THAT.
ON THE STAGE, CAME OFF AS REMOTE
AND MUTED.
AT TIMES AFRAID TO SPEAK
TRIPPING OVER WORDS AND
FORGETTING THEM.
SEVERAL TIMES THAT CAMERA CAUGHT
HIM STARING INTO THE MIDDLE
DISTANCE.
APPARENTLY ABSORBED IN MEMORY.
WHEN BIDEN DID MANAGE, HE SEEMS
HIGHLY ANNOYED.
WHATEVER THE CAUSE, DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARY VOTERS WERE NOT
IMPRESSED, DROPPED TEN POINTS
OVERNIGHT.
THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN NEVER
EXPLAINED EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED
TO JOE BIDEN THAT NIGHT IN
MIAMI.
BUT WHATEVER IT WAS, HE NEVER
GOT FIXED.
HE CONTINUES.
FROM THAT DAY UNTIL NOW,
PROBABLY THE MOST AUTHENTIC
FEATURE OF JOE BIDEN'S PUBLIC
PERFORMANCE HAS BEEN HIS ANGER,
WHICH SEEMS TO COME OVER HIM IN
WAVES.
WATCH.
>> FOCUS ON THIS MAN, WHAT HE'S
DOING, THAT NO PRESIDENT HAS
EVER DONE.
NO PRESIDENT.
>> WHY WOULD I TAKE A TEST?
COME ON, MAN!
THAT'S LIKE SAYING TO YOU THAT
BEFORE YOU GOT IN THIS PROGRAM
YOU ARE TAKING TESTS FOR TAKING
COCAINE OR NOT, WHAT DO YOU
THINK --
>> I'M GOING TO TALK!
HERE'S THE DEAL.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
FACT OF THE MATTER IS LOOK AT
WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE.
>> THAT'S NOT TRUE.
YOU ARE SAYING THINGS, YOU DO
NOT KNOW WHAT YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT.
WHO SAID THAT?
>> ISN'T THAT WHAT YOU SAID?
I'VE GOT TWO WORDS FOR YOU,
JACK.
>> THAT'S A GREAT ASSET.
ONE MORE QUESTION.
WHAT IS STUPID...
>> YOU KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THAT
IS.
YOU'VE SEEN IT AND PEOPLE AROUND
YOU, PEOPLE YOU LOVE.
NOTHING IN POLITICS.
WHAT YOU SAW AS A MAN WHOSE
LOSING HIS ABILITY TO REGULATE
HIS EMOTIONS.
FLASHES OF ANGER ARE COMMON
AMONG PEOPLE WHO ARE AGING,
AMONG MEN, AND IT OFTEN
ACCOMPANIES SENILITY.
LOSING IT IS A FRUSTRATING
EXPERIENCE IN MY HEART GOES OUT
TO ANYBODY WHO IS.
DEEP SYMPATHY FOR ANYONE IN THAT
POSITION INCLUDING JOE BIDEN.
BUT BIDEN IS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES AND THE SINGLE
MOST VOLATILE MOMENT IN THE
HISTORY OF OUR COUNTRY.
BIDEN IS LEADING THE U.S.
TOWARDS WAR.
IT'S FAIR TO ASSESS THE EFFECT
ON THE REST OF US TO THESE
EMOTIONAL CONDITION.
IT'S NOT SIMPLY ABOUT AGE.
BIDEN IS CLEARLY UNABLE TO SPEAK
WITH PRECISION.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND THE WORLD
HANGS ON YOUR EVERY WORD, WHEN
YOUR WORDS CONSTITUTE AMERICAN
POLICY AND YOU CAN CHANGE
AMERICAN POLICY, PARTICULATE
AMERICAN FOREIGN POLICY BY
SIMPLY SAYING SO, IT IS
ESSENTIAL THAT YOU SPEAK THE
WORDS YOU INTEND TO SPEAK BUT
YOU DON'T GET CARRIED AWAY
BECAUSE YOU ARE MAD AND SAVES
THEM AND YOU DON'T MEAN BUT
MIGHT THREATEN THE LONG-TERM
INTEREST OF THIS COUNTRY.
THREATEN THE FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN OF THE REST OF US AND
OUR FUTURE.
BUT HE IS.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HE'S DOING.
IT'S NOT A PARTISAN ATTACK.
IT'S TRUE.
IF YOU DOUBT THAT IT'S TRUE,
WATCHES PERFORMS JUST OVER THE
PAST WEEK.
ON THURSDAY FOR EXAMPLE,
JOE BIDEN WOULD ASK HOW THE
UNITED STATES RESPOND IF THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT USED CHEMICAL
WEAPONS IN UKRAINE.
THAT'S A HYPOTHETICAL QUESTION.
IMPOSSIBLE TO GET TO THOSE, THEY
RARELY RESPOND HYPOTHETICAL
QUESTIONS FOR THE SIMPLE REASON.
THEY DON'T KNOW THE
CIRCUMSTANCES AHEAD OF TIME.
SO THERE IS NO REASON TO RISK
AMERICAN PRESTIGE OR TO TERRIFY
THE REST OF THE WORLD BY SAYING
THE WRONG THING.
THEY DON'T.
BIDEN HAD NO OBLIGATION TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
VERY FEW PRESIDENTS WOULD'VE
ANSWERED BUT PETER TENDED
ANSWER.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID.
>> IF CHEMICAL WEAPONS WERE USED
IN UKRAINE, WHAT THAT TRIGGER A
MILITARY RESPONSE?
>> IT WOULD TRIGGER A RESPONSE
IN KIND WHETHER OR NOT YOU'RE
ASKING IF WE WOULD CROSS, WE
WOULD MAKE THAT DECISION AT THE
TIME.
>> Tucker: HE'S CLOSING HIS
EYES TO REMEMBER WHAT THE
CUE CARD SAID.
WHAT HE'S COME OUT WITH IS IF
RUSSIA USES CHEMICAL WEAPONS,
THE U.S. WILL RESPOND "IN-KIND."
IF RUSSIA USES CHEMICAL WEAPONS,
UNITED STATES WILL USE A
CHEMICAL WEAPON.
SOME NO AMERICAN PRESIDENT HAS
SAID ANYTHING LIKE THAT IN YOUR
LIFETIME.
YOU GREW UP ASSUMING THE
UNITED STATES WOULD NEVER USE
CHEMICAL WEAPONS BECAUSE THE
UNITED STATES IS NOT A ROGUE SET
DOWN NEXT DATE.
AARGH ROLL GLOBALLY IS TO
SUPPRESS ROGUE STATES.
AND YET IN A FLASH BECAUSE YOU
COULDN'T REMEMBER THE CORRECT
WORDS, JOE BIDEN, THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES, REVERSED
100 YEARS OF AMERICAN SECURITY
POLICY IN THE MIDDLE OF A WAR.
THIS DID NOT ESCAPE THE
ATTENTION OF IT OWN NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR WHO INSTANTLY
RESPONDED BY RESTORING THE
STATUS QUO OR ATTEMPTED TO.
UNITED STATES HAS NO INTENTION
OF USING CHEMICAL WEAPONS PERIOD
UNDER ANY CIRCUMSTANCES.
FLATLY CONTRADICTING HIS BOSS,
KNOWING HE WORKS FOR THE
PRESIDENT, HE WANTS TO DO THAT,
BUT JAKE SULLIVAN HAD NO CHOICE.
HE WORKS FOR A MAN WHO CANNOT
EVEN PRONOUNCE HIS OWN
VICE PRESIDENT'S NAME
CONSISTENTLY.
AND YET IS IN CHARGE OF THE
UNITED STATES AT ITS MOST
DELICATE MOMENT IN OUR
LIFETIMES.
BUT BIDEN DIDN'T SLOW DOWN.
HE KEPT GOING.
THE NEXT DAY HIS ADVISORS
ALLOWED HIM TO "RALLY THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY IN
SUPPORT OF UKRAINE.
AS CAMERAS ROLLED, JOE BIDEN
INFORMED OF THE SOLDIERS THAT
THEY WOULD SOON BE SENT TO
UKRAINE.
WATCH THIS.
>> LOOK HOW THEY ARE STEPPING
UP.
LOOK HOW THEY STEP UP.
YOU ARE GOING TO SEE WHEN YOU
THERE, YOU ARE GOING TO SEE
WOMEN, YOUNG PEOPLE STANDING UP
IN THE MIDDLE IN FRONT OF A DANG
TANK SAYING, I'M NOT LEAVING,
I'M HOLDING MY GROUND.
>> THE PREVIOUS PRESIDENT WAS
OFTEN CRITICIZED, SOME TIME WITH
JUSTIFICATION FOR NOT USING
WORDS.
YOU CAN'T JUST TWEET OUT
ANYTHING.
THAT'S THE CASE YOU HEARD FOR
FOUR YEARS.
IT WAS OFTEN ROOTED IN TRUTH.
THE LAST PRESIDENT NEVER SAID
ANYTHING THAT EVEN APPROACHES
THE RECKLESSNESS OF WHAT YOU
JUST HEARD.
YOU ARE GOING TO SEE, WHERE IN
UKRAINE, THEY ARE BORN IS GOING
TO DEEP.
THEY HAD NO IDEA, NETTED THEIR
FAMILIES, NEITHER DID ANYONE IN
UNITED STATES UNTIL JOE BIDEN
SET IT LIVE.
THE WHITE HOUSE DIDN'T EVEN
KNOW.
FOX NEWS REACHED OUT AFTER THOSE
REMARKS AND NO ONE THERE, NO ONE
IN THE WHITE HOUSE WERE AWARE
THAT THOSE COMMENTS WERE CAUGHT
ON TAPE.
SO HOW DO YOU EXPLAIN THIS
ABRUPT CHANGE IN AMERICAN
FOREIGN POLICY?
"THE PRESIDENT HAS MADE CLEAR
THAT WE ARE NOT SENDING U.S.
TROOPS TO UKRAINE AND THERE IS
NO CHANGE IN THAT POSITION."
FOR THE SECOND TIME IN THREE
DAYS, THE ADMINISTRATION HAS TO
FLATLY CONTRADICT THE COMMANDER
IN CHIEF.
AND NOT ON A MINOR QUESTION.
THESE ARE WRITTEN OFF AS A
GAFFE.
I GAFFE IS WHEN YOU MISPRONOUNCE
SOMEONE'S NAME.
UNITED STATES IS GOING TO USE
CHEMICAL WEAPONS?
THESE ARE NOT GAPS.
THESE ARE SOMETHING ELSE.
THEY ARE DANGEROUS.
THAT'S FOR SURE.
THE BEST THE WHITE HOUSE CAN DO
IS TELL US THAT THE PRESIDENT BY
SAYING HE SENDING AMERICAN
TROOPS TO UKRAINE, HE IS
REFERRING OUR POLICY OF NOT
SENDING TROOPS TO UKRAINE.
THANKS FOR THE CLARIFICATION.
IT GOT EVEN WEIRDER FROM THERE.
ONCE AGAIN COMPLETELY OUT OF
NOWHERE, NO WARNING WHATSOEVER,
AND APPARENTLY NO FORETHOUGHT,
JOE BIDEN CALLED FORAGING CHANGE
IN RUSSIA.
WATCH THIS.
>> A DICTATOR BENT ON REBUILDING
AN EMPIRE WHO WILL NEVER ERASE
PEOPLE'S LOVE FOR LIBERTY,
BRUTALITY WILL NEVER GRIND DOWN
THE WORLD.
FOR GOD'S SAKE, THIS MAN CANNOT
REMAIN IN POWER.
>> Tucker: DOING HIS CHURCH
HILL ROUTINE.
WHEN THINGS AREN'T GOING WELL AT
HOME, ALL PRESIDENTS TREAT -- HE
COULDN'T STOP HIMSELF.
"FOR GOD'S SAKE, THIS MAN CANNOT
REMAIN IN POWER."
JOE BIDEN SAID A VLADIMIR PUTIN.
YOU PROBABLY DON'T LIKE HIM AND
FOR GOOD REASON.
OUR POLICY ACCORDING TO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
IS TO TAKE BIDEN OUT, TO REMOVE
HIM AS HEAD OF STATE.
THE
TO THIS IS HARDLY THE FIRST TIME
WE'VE TANGLED.
UNITED STATES YOU RECALL WAGED A
PROXY WAR AGAINST THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT FOR 11 YEARS IN
VIETNAM.
NEARLY 60,000 AMERICANS DIED IN
THAT WAR.
AND YET NO AMERICAN PRESIDENT
MENTION REGIME CHANGE AT THE
KREMLIN.
WHY?
THEY WERE SOFT ON THE RUSSIANS?
NO.
RUSSIA HAS ABOUT 6,000 NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
WHAT SAY WE ELIMINATED THE
RUSSIAN HEAD OF STATE AND THAT
COUNTRIES SOCIAL GOVERNMENT.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN TO THOSE
WEAPONS?
LET'S SEE.
IN IRAQ, SADDAM'S POK STYLE WENT
INTO THE HANDS OF MILITIAS USED
TO KILL AMERICANS.
RUSSIA HAS A LARGE AND RESTIVE
POPULATION OF ISLAMIC EXTREMIST
AND WE THINK THAT IT'S POSSIBLE
WITH NO ONE AROUND THE COUNTRY,
WE HAVE NO CHOSEN SUCCESSOR TO
PUTIN, IF WE DID THAT ONE OF THE
6,000 NUCLEAR WEAPONS MIGHT WIND
UP IN THE HANDS OF SOME
ANTI-AMERICAN TERROR GROUP AND
BE USED AGAINST OUR CIVILIAN
POPULATION HERE?
A NUCLEAR WEAPON!
IT'S NOT JUST POSSIBLE, IT'S
LIKELY.
AND THAT'S IF WE WERE TO SUCCEED
IN KILLING PUTIN.
WHAT IF WE DON'T?
APPARENTLY IT'S NOW THE POLICY.
THE PRESIDENT OF UNITED STATES
INFORMED THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT
THAT HE SEEKS ITS OVERTHROW.
YOU HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF, DOES
HEARING THAT MAKE VLADIMIR PUTIN
MORE OR LESS LIKELY TO USE A
NUCLEAR WEAPON AGAINST THE
UNITED STATES AND WESTERN
EUROPE.
HOW TO TRAP ANIMALS BEHAVE?
THEY LASH OUT.
DESPERATE PEOPLE ARE DANGEROUS
PEOPLE, OF COURSE.
SO WOULD BE IN THE INTEREST OF
THE UNITED STATES AND THAT'S THE
ONLY INTEREST THAT MATTERS FROM
OUR PERSPECTIVE, TO COOL THE
RHETORIC A LITTLE BIT.
OR WHEN YOU EMPLOY OVER SEEDED
RHETORIC IS TO DO IT FOR A
REASON, IN THE SERVICE OF A
CLEARLY ARTICULATED GOAL THAT
HELPS THE UNITED STATES AND NOT
BECAUSE YOU ARE OLD, WHICH IS
WHAT YOU JUST SAW.
A GUY WHO JUST LOST CONTROL OF
WHAT HE WAS SAYING BECAUSE HE
WAS TOO MAD.
IT'S ALL PRETTY OBVIOUS BUT NO
ONE IN WASHINGTON HAS SPENT 30
SECONDS THEY CAN ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED IF WE KNOCKED OFF
PUTIN.
OUR FOREIGN POLICY ESTABLISHMENT
SPENT THE WEEKEND CONGRATULATING
JOE BIDEN ON SAYING THE WRONG
THING WHERE THEY COMPARED HIM TO
RONALD REAGAN.
WASHINGTON LOVES REGIME CHANGE.
IT'S WHAT COMES AFTER REGIME
CHANGE THEY'D RATHER NOT
CONSIDER AND HAVE NO TRACK
RECORD OF PULLING OFF.
BUT FOR NOW, THEY WERE THRILLED.
BILL KRISTOL COMPARED BIDEN'S
THREAT TO DRAGON, TO TELLING
GORBACHEV TO TEAR DOWN THIS
WALL.
RICK WILSON AGREED.
"BIDEN DID TEAR DOWN THIS WALL
FOR OUR ERA" FOR THE CLICHE,
DUMB PEOPLE SPEAK AND THINKING
CLICHES.
FORMER WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
CBS NEWS MARK NOLLER SAID BIDEN
WAS BETTER THAN REAGAN.
TO HIS CREDIT FOR ONCE, THE
WHITE HOUSE DID NOT RUN TOWARD
THE APPLAUSE NOTE.
APPARENTLY ADULTS ARE STILL
WORKING THERE AND MUTELY TOLD US
THAT BIDEN HADN'T MEANT WHAT HE
TOLD US IN CAMERA, DIDN'T MEAN
IT.
THEY SAY THAT IT WAS ALIVE.
THE PRESIDENT OF POTTER'S POINT,
WE CAN DISCERN HIS POINT!
HE SAID THAT THE PRESIDENT'S
POINT IS THAT BIDEN CANNOT BE
ALLOWED TO EXERCISE POWER OVER
HIS NEIGHBORS IN THE REGION.
HE WAS NOT DISGUSTING PUTIN'S
POWER IN RUSSIA OR REDEEM
CHANGE.
IT'S NOT TRUE, BUT IT'S
REASSURING TO KNOW THAT OUR
POLICY REMAINS THE SAME.
NEOCONS IN D.C. WERE HIGHLY
DISTRESSED.
CIA OPERATIVE RODNEY BARON WROTE
THIS, THIS WOULD'VE BEEN BIDEN'S
TEAR DOWN THE WALL MOMENT, BUT
FOR STAFFERS WATERING DOWN THE
MEANING AFTERWARD.
A FEW HOURS AGO, BIDEN ONCE
AGAIN STEPPED IN FRONT OF THE
MICROPHONE AND REAFFIRMED THAT
THE WORDS THAT ACTUALLY SLIPPED
OUT OF HIS MOUTH THIS WEEKEND
ARE ACTUALLY OFFICIALLY U.S.
POLICY.
HERE IS JOE BIDEN.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE WHAT YOU SAID,
THAT PUTIN CANNOT REMAIN IN
POWER, OR DO YOU REGRET SAYING
THAT, BECAUSE YOUR GOVERNMENT
HAS BEEN TRYING TO WALK THAT
BACK.
DOES YOUR WORDS COMPLICATE
MATTERS?
>> YOU ASKED THREE DIFFERENT
QUESTIONS AND I'LL ANSWER THEM
ALL.
NUMBER ONE, I'M NOT WALKING
ANYTHING BACK.
>> SO REGIME CHANGE IN RUSSIA IS
NOW OUR POLICY.
THAT'S WHAT THE PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES HAS JUST TOLD US.
AND AS HE DID, HE REVIEWED THE
PEOPLE WHO WORKED WITH HIM, THEY
SPEND ALL WEEK CORRECTING
STATEMENTS THAT HE MAKES UP ON
THE FLY AND HASN'T THOUGHT
THROUGH IN ANY WAY.
PURELY A REACTION OF, HEY, WOULD
BE THE LONG-TERM EFFECTS OF WHAT
YOU ARE DOING?
NO IDEA.
WHEN EVERYTHING IS SUDDENLY AT
STAKE THEM AND NEVER BEEN
RECKLESSNESS AT THIS LEVEL AND
THAT INCLUDES THE LAST PRESIDENT
WHO WAS OFTEN ATTACKED FOR BEING
RECKLESS.
NOTHING SAID COMPARES TO THIS.
FOX'S PETER DOOCY ASK FOR
CLARIFICATION.
JOE BIDEN REVEALED THAT HE'S
COMPLETELY UNAWARE THAT HIS
STAFF HAS BEEN UPDATING AMERICAN
POLICY ALL WEEK AS HE CHANGES
THAT "ON-THE-FLY."
WATCH JOE BIDEN.
>> ARE YOU WORRIED OTHER LEADERS
IN THE WORLD ARE GOING TO START
A DOUBT THAT AMERICA IS BACK IF
SOME OF THESE BIG THINGS THAT
YOU SAY ON THE WORLD STAGE KEEP
GETTING WALKED BACK?
>> PUTIN'S THE ONE WHO MADE
LET'S WALK BACK.
>> IT'S AND THE LIKE YOU TOLD
U.S. TROOPS ARE GOING TO UKRAINE
FOR YOU SOUND LIKE IT WAS
POSSIBLE THAT YOU WOULD USE A
CHEMICAL WEAPON AND IT SOUNDED
LIKE YOU ARE CALLING FOR REGIME
CHANGE IN RUSSIA AND WE KNOW --
>> NONE OF THE THREE ARE
CORRECT.
>> NONE --
>> NONE OF THE THREE ARE
CORRECT.
>> MR. PRESIDENT --
>> AND YOU INTERPRET THAT
LANGUAGE THAT WAY...
>> Tucker: WHAT'S GETTING...
BERNIE SANDERS SCARED THE HELL
OUT OF THE BANKS.
DEMOCRAT PARTY SHORT-CIRCUITED
HIS CAMPAIGN AND INSTALL
JOE BIDEN.
BIDEN SEEMED PASSIVE, THAT WAS A
WELCOME RESPITE FROM THE LAST
PRESIDENT, AND SEEING
KAMALA HARRIS DOWN THE GLASS.
NOBODY ANTICIPATED AT THE MOMENT
THAT WE WOULD BE ON THE CUSP OF
A WAR WITH A NUCLEAR ARMED POWER
IN LESS THAN TWO YEARS.
EXACTLY WHERE WE ARE NOW AND
THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES, SOMEONE WHO
LITERALLY HAS NO IDEA WHAT'S
GOING ON, WHEN HE DOES THIS, IS
IT SCARY TO DESCRIBE THAT?
NO, IT'S WORSE.
BIDEN SAID THAT EVERYTHING HE
HAS SAID FOR THE LAST WEEK IS
TRUE AND NONE OF IT HAS BEEN
CORRECTED BY PEOPLE WHO WORK FOR
HIM.
THE TRUTH IS JOE BIDEN HAS NO
IDEA.
JOE BIDEN HAS NO IDEA, HIS
PUBLICIST SAY, WHEN HE GOES TO
SLEEP.
BIDEN STARTS WALKING BACK HIS
OWN COMMENTS, SAYING THAT AFTER
HE SAID HE'D NEVER WALK BACK HIS
OWN COMMENT.
NONE OF THAT OCCURRED.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE WE ARE BEING
MEAN TO THE GUY BY QUOTING HIM
AND NO ONE WANTS THAT.
NO ONE IS MAKING OF HIS AGE OR
HIS DIMINISHED CONDITION.
MOMENTS LATER, BIDEN DECLARED
THAT NO REASONABLE PERSON WOULD
THINK HE WANTS REGIME CHANGE IN
RUSSIA.
WATCH THIS, IF YOU CAN STAND IT.
>> IT'S RIDICULOUS!
NOBODY BELIEVES WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE DOWN...
I WAS TALKING ABOUT TAKING DOWN
PUTIN.
NOBODY BELIEVES THAT.
>> JOKE IS OVER.
TOO MUCH IS AT STAKE.
IF THERE EVER WAS A TIME, IF
THERE WAS EVER A TIME TO INVOKE
THE 20TH AMENDMENT, IT I